先说我的原生家庭，
我是独生女，
以前我父母在一起过得特别压抑，
我小时候身体不好，
但都是小毛病，
没花过大钱，
他们也因为我花我要花钱的原因经常吵架。
初中的时候，
我妈要带我去北京看病，
我爸说可以，
但是回来就要领离婚证。
其实这个时候他俩是想着假离婚，
但是是真要领了离婚证，
我妈为了能带我去北京，
他就答应了，
所以我家的房子归了我爸。
后来几年他俩还是在一起过，
那个时候我妈特别傻，
他掏钱借钱帮我爸买了个车，
开出租车，
但是欠条或者是他掏了多少钱的证据都没有，
再加上我妈的钱一直在补贴家用，
主要是给我用，
没攒下多少。
他俩很多年都在，
都不在一起税，
不一起吃钱都是各花各的。
我爸脾气很暴躁，
一点小事吵完架就是冷暴力，
我妈完全就是为了我，
一直忍着和他过。
所以等到我大学的时候，
我妈就彻底下了决心，
宁愿房子车了，
钱啥都不要了，
净算出户也不过了。
我和我妈就搬出来租了房子。
我爸不愿意，
她觉得她没同意，
也不止一次闹过，
闹过一年平息了。
后来我妈瞒着她又找了一个男人，
就是再婚了。
这个人就是我叔，
他性格特别好，
也很拘谨。
徐霞对我和我妈都特别照顾，
他俩在一起之后，
我才知道幸福的家庭是什么样的。
但缺点就是早些年他陪了大钱，
和前妻离婚了，
女儿也不跟他，
现在他女儿已经结完婚生完孩子了，
那个时候还在念大学了，
我们三个都没啥钱，
特别困难，
就住在我妈租的房子里。
后来我爸知道了我妈再婚的事情，
就上了往死里闹，
说我妈这一辈子就只能是这他的他的女人。
我们趁着他居留的时候，
卖完家里的东西，
把所有的联系方式都换了。
我男又往北周转了好几个城市，
已经过去两三年了，
他俩的感情现在还是特别好，
我特别感动于他俩相处的状态，
重新也让我对婚姻有了信心。
现在的情况是我已经工作一年了，
我们在新的城市也稳定下来，
不想再租房子了，
他们考虑买房子，
我叔把我手里，
把他手里的钱都给我妈，
他俩一起能有5万，
他俩想着再攒一攒，
借点钱，
明年买不了就后年买，
买一套十几万的二手房，
就先凑合过，
先凑合。
他俩没花过我手里的钱，
我一直攒着了，
到年底至少能攒5万，
我现在还有2万的公积金，
我想问的就是我要掺和到他那买房子的事情啊，
我现在23岁，
没有对象，
也没想好要不要自己。
贷款买个房子，
我们现在还住在一起，
我特别想帮他们，
要怕真到哪一天他俩过不到一起去了，
这个房子难办，
我怕重蹈覆辙。
姐姐，
你能给我出个主意吗？
你现在23岁，
你现在自己工作了吗？
工作了一年了，
嗯，
现在你的这个攒的这个钱是你自己工作这一年攒的是不是。
对，
再加上我大学的时候有那个奖学金咋的，
现在他们想要买这个房子是登记在谁名下，
他俩就是想着放他俩两个人的名字，
他俩已经领证了吗？
领证了，
他想让你帮是什么意思呢？
就是说你你手上影想让我，
但是我想啊，
因为我手上现在攒了一点了啊，
你手上现在总共攒了几万块钱，
两万五万啊，
嗯，
还有2万公积金，
我感觉是这样啊，
他俩呢过日子呢，
嗯，
你你你琢磨一下，
就是你当时读大学的时候，
你这个书，
嗯，
在你身上投资没有给你花了多少钱，
是不是没花过多少钱，
基本都是我拉过头的，
那如果你妈现在暂时没有开这个口的话，
我觉得咱也这样，
你好不容易你攒了5万块钱，
你自己以后想学点啥呀，
呃，
想买点啥呀，
或者想换工作呀，
公司里面有什么更好的发展呀，
对吧，
想去培训呀什么的，
这最起码对于你来说是一种就是能掉头的这么一个掉头钱嘛。
没必要都把它砸到这个房子上，
然后他俩要是想买房子的话，
有多大能耐咱就买多大房是吧，
有多大力量，
咱就是这个买多大的房呗，
是不是啊，
那你现在手这个钱啊，
对于你来说特别关键，
他的关键点在于什么呢？
前段时间就有个妹妹来跟我说，
他说嗯，
姐，
我都不敢辞职，
我单位有人欺负我，
因为我手上没有钱，
你知道吗？
你有个5万块钱了，
你在单位了，
你干的不开心了，
谁欺负你了，
你能换单位，
你能对吧，
你能重新找工作呀，
你能掉头啊，
比如说遇到什么好的工作机会呀，
人家那个工作机会说前三个月实习没给多少钱了，
但是你又觉得特别有前景啊，
你这个5万块钱就能够支撑你去做这样的人生选择呀，
嗯，
我主要是想帮他们，
是因为我特别心疼我妈，
我觉得他太辛苦，
太辛苦了，
你，
你他现在有有一个叔叔对他好，
他就不辛苦，
我告诉你女人就是这样，
他可以吃的差一点，
可以穿的差一点，
她就在身边有人对他好，
他不辛苦，
对于他来说的话，
如果以后你能日子过得更好，
对于他来说带来的那种精神上的愉悦，
其实比他住80㎡的房子还是住70米的房子，
那个那个心情愉悦的程度更更高，
就是说现在对于来说的话，
住80㎡和住70㎡没太大差别，
换句话说，
你这5万块钱能够起到的作用不就是。
包个10㎡，
少个10㎡的作用吗？
嗯，
对对，
是我想让我妈就是平松一点，
是不是觉得这些年太累了，
然后我就想让他不要干那么累的工作了，
现在工作太累了，
你的目光要放长远一点，
就是你现在这5万块钱怼到你你妈妈和你叔叔身上的话，
是不会对他们的幸福指数有数量级的提升的，
不会改变他们那个数量级的，
他不外乎就是说买的这个家具是有品牌的还是没品牌的，
是买的这个沙发是有造型的和没造型的是这么个区别，
但不影响他的那个幸福指数。
什么时候你有好的前途，
有好的工作机会，
你工作开心，
你德育良人，
你的人生顺遂，
对于你妈妈来说才是幸福指数最高的事儿。
姐姐我懂的，
其实我就是我妈的后盾，
他一直也说的，
我让我掺和他们的事情，
对，
就这意思，
好吧，
那我就是借一部分给他们可以吧，
你自己手上怎么也得留够你一年的生活费嘛，
三万三万多嘛，
至少吧，
嗯，
主要是我现在工作很稳定了，
因为是那个事业单位，
你工作很稳定，
现在哪有稳定的工作呀，
你就应该是多花心思去学习新的东西，
学习什么东西能够在呃，
不违法不犯罪的情况下，
还能多挣点钱，
我懂。
那我还想问问，
就是我爸这边，
我现在还是不联系他，
今年开始才逢年过节的时候点外卖给他买点东西放门口，
我现在还是很怕他，
我要是以后嗯，
一直过不了心里里坎，
我能不管他吗？
或者是他有啥这就的办法吗？
他自己啊，
他要是有退休金，
他是有钱，
他能吃得上饭，
能有地方住的话，
你可以不用管他。
法律上他有有自己的房子，
然后开出租车也赚钱，
那你就可以不用管他啊，
因为法律上规定是他没有生活来源，
或者说生活很困难，
对吧，
他才有资格要求儿女去给他赡养费，
嗯，
哎，
姐姐，
我现在工作也挺好的，
但是受家庭影响这么大，
我都很自卑，
这个心态一时半会儿转不过来，
单位同事很多都还给我介绍对象，
我不反感相亲，
但是对开始处对象这个事情特别纠结，
总感觉我家庭情况复杂，
又没啥钱，
配不上别人，
当然也有可能是我还没遇到合适的人，
你能建一建议我适合找什么样的人嘛，
因为你现在也是事业单位啊，
收入也很稳定对吧，
你才23岁，
你自己，
呃，
叫什么也挺节省的啊，
你工作时间不长，
你还能攒下来钱，
其实你本身的条件是很好的。
就本身条件是啥也不差事嘛，
对吧，
也是大学毕业，
然后正经的工作，
年纪又那么轻，
你本身是没有任何问题的，
可能就是说从原生家庭这个角度来说，
哎，
爸爸不靠谱，
嗯，
对吧，
妈妈再婚了，
我觉得你妈妈再婚了，
只要妈妈他，
嗯，
没有病，
没有灾，
没有负担，
不拖你的后腿，
妈妈这头也没少毛病，
而且你跟你爸爸少联系，
不联系你爸妈那头也不会成为你的负担，
你现在就是属于没什么负担的一个一个状态，
是吧？
对，
那你你要是属于这样一个状态的话，
人家其实给你介绍对象的时候，
你自己也应该把自己的优势放在这儿呀，
我没负担呀，
我爸妈都能养活自己啊，
我不需要养活我爸妈呀，
是吧，
我挣的钱都自己花呀，
我挣的钱都可以安排我自己的学习啊，
我自己将来的这个成长啊，
呃，
想参加什么培训啊，
我都可以去啊，
这都是你的优势啊，
当然我觉得啊，
女孩子颜值这一块还是得投资的，
这是我说大实话，
如果皮肤不好的话，
好好的护肤是吧，
如果头发稀疏的话，
好好的护理头发，
如果说哎，
觉得自己身材哪儿不匀称的话，
好好的练一练身材，
这是实话，
如果觉得自己穿衣服咋扮，
嗯，
没有人家那么好看的话，
咱也学学化妆，
学一学穿衣打扮，
嗯，
我不是外貌自卑，
我就是总感觉就是我的那个纠结的事情太多了就是。
嗯，
你可能适合找一个性格大大咧咧一点，
开朗一点儿的，
你能够啊，
就遇到像我朋一样的，
就是总感觉就是很难迈出那一步，
要不然哪，
你不着急，
你想一下子有人说让我提升自己，
嗯，
我知道了，
好吧，
好，
谢谢大家啊，
嗯，
拜拜，
就是一个劲儿一个劲的对自己好啊，
资源把钱这个东西都堆到自己身上，
年轻的时候真是要这样。